tens of millions of Americans on the
East Coast are being pummeled by a
winter storm that's being called a bomb
cyclone the powerful system with snow
ice and lashing winds could bring more
than a foot of snow to the Northeast you
can see heavy snow falling right now in
Atlantic City New Jersey Boston could
get up to 17 inches in Portland Maine up
to 11 this huge storm spans nearly the
entire length of the eastern seaboard
red highlights show how blizzard
warnings stretched from North Carolina
to Maine wind gusts of up to 70 miles an
hour are predicted in some spots our
correspondents are in the thick of the
storm from Georgia to Massachusetts we
begin with Omar Villafranca in Norfolk
Virginia where the snow is coming down
hard
Omar good morning good morning the City
of Norfolk is under a blizzard warning
and they haven't had one of these since
the 1980s and the city is essentially
shut down city services schools even
public transportation is all closed
today now ahead of the storm the
governor of Virginia declared a state of
emergency overnight on Interstate 264
cars became stuck in the snow the
Virginia Department of Transportation
has more than 1500 workers and 1,400
pieces of equipment working 12-hour
shifts responding to the storm now high
winds are another major concern in the
state bridges are at a higher risk of
freezing and the Chesapeake area has
over 90 of them all of them have been
sprayed with brine to keep them from
becoming sheets of ice now in
neighboring Maryland the governor
declared a state of emergency for three
counties in the Lower Shores area some
areas there could see up to a foot of
snow
now last checked with Dominion energy
about 36,000 people are without power
because of the storm and that's going to
be an issue because temperatures today
are only expected to get to 32 degrees
if they're lucky 33 degrees Jeff Omar
thank you very much